you know why I did it star much hmm
that's a star much I did it because I
wanted to what are we even talking about
this for we just had a little man save
us by blowing up 50 ships how little
well I like this a little one-inch man
saved us well if they got closer I'm
sure he'd be much larger
that's how eyesight works you stupid
raccoon don't call her our code I'm
sorry I took it too far
I meant trash manda is that better oh
it's of course Hey so much worse I hope
you're ready it'll be here any minute is
that a rifle you do know what a rifle
looks like it's just swords were your
thing and gun for mine but I guess we
both doing guns now I just didn't know
that well
I see it within you there Jelinek the
prayer is about using to cleanse the
universe of the sweetness
you know they told me you people were
conceited douchebags but that isn't true
at all
dude I'm using my wrong I put your
seatbelt on
[Music]
[Applause]
Hey
[Music]
so with saving the galaxy again we're
really gonna be able to jack up our
price it for two-time galaxy Davis
[Music]
yeah
sometimes the thing you're searching for
your whole life
it's right there by your side all along
your right family
familiar
after all these years I've found you and
who the hell are you I'm your dad Peter
[Music]
you